as cases increase we are all eager to
know when a vaccine will be rolled out
joe mohler joining us live and joe you
spoke to a medical expert
a man who volunteered to be part of one
of the vaccine trials joe
yeah the man we spoke spoke with today
says that the news of modernist vaccine
trial
and the effectiveness of it that came
out earlier today is exciting
especially as these cases continue to go
up
but i just kind of wanted to try it to
get involved in something
michael burton is an attorney here in
southern nevada he says in the summer he
came across an ad for people to
participate in the modernic open 19
vaccine trial
i've been following what was going on
with covet and i thought maybe this
would be it
you know they need people i can get
involved and maybe i can be a part of
trying to
move past this starting in july burton
says he went in for two different rounds
of shots and kept a diary of how he felt
half of the participants took a placebo
the other half were given the vaccine
i never had any side effects at all
even from the injection itself which i
usually do get some
bruising and whatnot but i didn't have i
had
nothing basically no no actual side
effects and no physical side effects
monday modern reported the vaccine is
94.5 percent effective
it is consistent with pfizer's trial in
that it shows a vaccine efficacy of
over 90 percent meaning that it prevents
over 90 of cases
of the copenhagen disease medical expert
sam sun is from kobe 19
think tank non-profit endemic foundation
sun expects the data to be reviewed in
the coming weeks and frontline workers
to have the vaccine before the end of
the year
a lot of it now has to do with how fast
regulatory agencies can move and how
fast
the companies and their partners can
move in terms of manufacturing the
vaccine and get it distributed to
hospitals and clinics around the country
burton says the sooner it gets out
the better what i'm hoping for out of
this is with this vaccine
with the pfizer vaccine with the johnson
johnson on the horizon
is that we can get ahead of this thing
and kind of get back to normal
now the modern vaccine trial is ongoing
burton says he still has to do some more
blood work here
in the near future reporting live joe
moeller 8 news now